the world can be a toxic place
no one knows this more than women and
girls
cis and trans
as well as non-binary people
i am a journalist with 30 years
experience reporting on the injustices
women others face around the world
i am a co-founder of the man-up campaign
to energize youth activism against
sexual and gender-based violence i'm a
father to two daughters
i'm a life partner to a woman
and i'm a black man in america
holding these identities and many more
i say this call to action to you
with the deepest sincerity and utmost
gravity
it is time
for a gender reckoning
beginning with men
authentically confronting
our internal selves and each other
divide the toxicity within us
against the backdrop
a black lives matter protest
cries for a racial reckoning have echoed
throughout the world
at times seeming premature and largely
misunderstood
i believe
our true gender reckoning
must be the center of any transformative
movement for social justice and equity
but what is a reckoning
dictionary state means to resolve a bill
or a debt
in other words to settle an account
in the case of women girls
what is the debt owed to them
who's to pay it
and how
the consequences of male toxicity
continue building the debt to which i
refer including among others a gender
wealth gap
most affecting women who care for their
families
as well as act as the primary income
generators for their households
today
in the united states and abroad
threats to reproductive justice endanger
the lives and hard-fought rights of
women
in regards to their bodily
sexual
and gender autonomy
impacting the most disenfranchised
community in society
and violence against women in all of its
forms
still represents an existential
challenge
as we've seen domestic violence rise in
the pandemic as people confined to their
homes
we've seen online public harassment
flourish unabated
the sexual trafficking
prostitution exploitation
of women and girls thrives as ever
before
from where does this toxicity come
and why
men are not endangered
we're not under assault
we're not being unfairly maligned
in fact there's men
or the certain masculinities that are
the issue
to be clear
being a man does not make me
anyone else who identifies as a man
inherently
toxic but masculinity in certain forms
can harm women
girls
non-binary people and men
through violence
dominating power and
control so how do we address this
how can we men
step up
and better support our daughters
our sisters
our female partners
our colleagues neighbors and friends
through what means can men both
instigate
and lead a gender reckoning
first
we must tell the truth
we must
tell the truth
men grow into this world
becoming who we're expected to be
or who we think we're expected to be
based on cultural expectations
and inaccurate historical narratives
a short chubby black kid wearing glasses
growing up
i was repeatedly told
i cried too much
i'm too emotional too soft
it was ingrained in me and to prove my
masculinity
i had to display physical prowess
intimidation
because of that indoctrination
as an adult
i refuse to seek help
facing escalating health challenges
including high blood pressure
and mental trauma
the archetype of manhood
nearly killed me
i say that
as a survivor of two heart attacks
four years on dialysis
and a kidney transplant
aside from the physical risk i put
myself into covering wars around the
world
the injury we do to ourselves
the woman around us
comes from fear
of losing control
of lack of external affirmation
and simply out of shame
man has a spectrum of identities
there is no one way to be a man
and sometimes discovering one's true
manhood is a lifelong journey
secondly
we must be consistent
men
especially men of color
cannot expect women
to stand up for us
with us
in the face of systemic oppressions
when too often
we do not do the same for them
[Applause]
the black lives matter movement for
example
founded
named
and led by queer women of color
still centers
black men's well-being
in the face of unfair policing
and criminal justice systems
and where is the reciprocal support from
those men including myself
in addressing intra-community violence
against women of color
maternal health inequity
economic disparity
how and where do men show up for women
i wonder
how many men stood with women
on the steps of the u.s supreme court
as they fought for reproductive rights
how many men should have been there
finally
there can be no reckoning
without accountability
there can be no reckoning
without accountability
men who commit acts of violence against
women
must be held accountable by formal
systems of justice
as well as other men
silence in the face of misogynistic
behavior and language
is complicity
we men
need to break free from the pack
take concrete actions
to stop violence
create safety
and build equity
and most importantly
say something
to be sure
bold men around us are actively working
to disrupt the narrative of male
toxicity
after the 2010 earthquake in haiti
a local organization
kofaviv
invited men to be defenders of women and
girls and displacement camps
women and girls were at risk of sexual
assault
scores of men answer the call and
continue to do so today
in new york city
connect nyc
led by a black man
actively engages community partners
across civil society to address family
violence
and
in a profession not known generally for
its advocacy against gender violence a
professional player of the washington
football team
has become an unabashed advocate for men
to learn
and actively change behaviors
regarding sexual and physical violence
there is hope there is light
men around the world are putting the
work to catalyze a true gender reckoning
but far more needed
what i want to say to you today is this
too many of us too many men
don't understand
that equity
justice
inclusivity
safety
for women
girls and non-binary people
serves and saves us all
broken masculinity harm societies
full stop
when we men reckon with that truth
we will finally find our shared humanity
women
girls
non-binary people
men
staying together on equal footing with
mutual respect and safe environments
is the greatest gender reckoning we can
create
thank you